as always our recordings of our virtual
meetups will be available on youtube
about a week after the meetup and we'll
post a message on meetup when the
recording is ready
next i am very pleased to introduce our
speaker today
joshua herman
joshua herman is a python developer
working on currency trading
infrastructure with bank of america
he is also an amateur data engineer
applying generative machine learning to
create art make fake tweets and write
novels
he also does abstract art using pastels
to write music and poetry
to date we'll handle all of our
questions at the end so if you have
questions feel free to write them down
in the chat throughout
but i'll read them to joshua all at the
end in the order that they received
take it away joshua
hello um
yeah so
you know introduce myself again i'm
writing a visual novel that doesn't
exist
and on
possibly releasing an alpha version by
december but
i've been working on this project around
a year or two
really wanted to
explore
on how you could somehow like
elevate video games like in a new
direction
i think that
this may have applications and metaverse
but
um
i did
plan on this
having
eventually an ar or vr component or at
least a video component
has maybe a sequel or a better version
but
as you know i'm python developer bank of
america
i'm an amateur data engineer
which means
i
don't really
create new models i just work with
existing models to apply them
to
complete
objectives
right now i'm
looking into video games
specifically
visual novels
so first you want to know why we are
here
so a lot of people
in the group may be familiar with
obviously machine learning applied to
non-video game contexts like
for example
regression
anomaly detection
and so um
naive bayes
but
video games well while we have seen a
lot of them with the procedural
techniques
they usually
limit themselves
in the artistic
manner that they're created
for me
to give you an example
um
zelda
mario brothers and so forth
have a lot of sprites
or even
or they went from 2d to 3d models after
you know
super mario 64.
and while
and even
and
even left 4 dead 2 which had uh
ai game master to
maybe either change the difficulty or
change situations
it's it's a very big
part of any video game where you have
in-game assets
anything from voice acting
to
line to art in general
to even uh lore or stories that you want
to tell
for example in the original super mario
brothers they had large limitations on
the design
of mario
the limitations were that he had to be
recognizable within i think he's
three by eight pixels
but
that actually
made him a plumber and italian or
yeah a problem and a plumber and they're
like
i don't know if it was a italian they
added that in i think later or that
might have been the original i don't
know um
but
you can see that because of that they
need like red and black and uh
you know white
in that
context
um
and the same with um luigi and every
single spike including
like bowser browser you have the
you had to be able to recognize a person
immediately when you started the game
and they had to and you had to
understand
like what the character sprites are
there but these were still hand coded
even
even the even the clouds are actually a
pallet swap for the green grass
and uh
so
and even agent behavior is a big part
but it's relatively hard anyways because
you're basically having an ai
go through a graph where it can be
reachable and a lot of art
in the game
can clip through very easily
because you have this like abstract
you have this 3d model you have like
bounding boxes on it and
because you can clip through sometimes
you can do
um you can do
the physics can glitch out now
that's not to say that generative
techniques can fix that but
it would be make would be making video
games a lot more interesting because you
could just never stop playing them
or they could have open-ended situations
and maybe you don't have the skill to
create
art for video games
like i don't think
i don't
know how to do this i actually do 2d art
i'm able to actually use um these
techniques to do it
uh in generative art
you actually explain the latent space of
of the high dimensional data
but
instead of just um so you so you look at
us at a slice of it and you look not if
like if it
is uh you look at them and you can
actually
a lot of these tools well i'll show
later as a video
that the latent space can be
stepped through in various ways
and
also
going back to what i said before
breaking the rules of other kinds of
video games
i'll go i'll expand on that when i
introduce the visual novel component
so let's go go a little bit of theory we
had to we i went down a little bit
theory there
and um so
going back generative machine learning
the objective is to mimic
an existing set of observations
to the like the above task itself to
create an approximate value as the task
so
instead of
so when you're sampling the latent space
you're really just looking at
points in between
the high dimensional space
various slices and you a lot of
attributes can be
as parameters and and it really works
pretty well with
gans specifically
um 2d
um
data
to like anime so
there's a few few reasons for that one
is that there's this model
called waifu 2x which is not a joke but
it sounds like a joke but
where it automatically upscales or
denoises any image that's in anime
and i think that's what really got
people into it
because of the single task that you
could upscale anything a lot of people
like liked art so they would ups they
but they may have really bad pictures so
they just take the deep learning model
and just up and then just apply it and
you now have an upscale version like but
i and if you're not familiar with images
and upscaling um think about
like
think about if you have a 4k television
and you have a 1080p signal upscaling to
4k would be to take the 1080p signal and
either spread it out on the 4k
television and also infer some of the
points on it
nvidia has dl
dlss on their video cards now that can
do certain upscaling
although it sort of seems
somewhat it can't huh which
was sort of 1.0 was had some weird bugs
where
you could see that there
but the second version of it i think
fixed them although i don't
i don't really play a lot of games that
have that feature because it's play
different kind but i know it exists but
the the anime version works so well
there it is you are generally instructed
after you create any art is to pump it i
mean to input it to wi-fi 2x anyways
because it denoises the image so you get
a better signal regardless of what it is
it doesn't matter
everybody and it's a
and really it's a good
it presents advantage
to anything else
so first
there's sort of an interesting thing
that i had to do and this is i believe
original work and i'm not familiar
with it so the visual novel um
sort of like a this whole novel i'm
trying to write is sort of like a
simulation of a dating game
but the game master
i have is um
you could think of it as a state machine
with
achievements
um where you can unlock states
i also want the states to be
created randomly or procedurally
but you have a set of achievements and
how how it works is the key master
applies sentiment analysis to the input
and output
to the user's input and allows them to
proceed or not proceed
i'm gonna get
well i'm gonna just look we'll go into
this a lot further
so more into the gamework
master is
so i was watching youtube one day when i
was working you know i shouldn't do that
but um so there was a relationship
researcher john gottman and he used this
magic ratio of five to one where
successful intermittent relationships
has a balance between
positive and every feelings
and actions between partners so
and also there's a fifteen to one to
back off
that you shouldn't eat weeds so it's
bounded actually from 5 to 1 and 15 to
1.
now
with this ratio i can apply that to the
sensitive analysis portion to actually
figure out
to make the user have
to program the game master
the game master then becomes just a
system that does sentiment analysis
and i might actually and i'm going to do
is i'm probably going to add it
to
the user um just for monitoring purposes
or even
to also look at ground truth because a
lot of psychological
techniques
have low observations of ground truth
when i worked at uh be um at a social
network
um lab when i was still at school as a
it's just an undergrad um
programmer
and there's also um so
obviously i can implement this ratio by
just taking the sentiment analysis
and the sentence with the analysis is
either positive or negative so i just
have i just maintain two counters i have
a counter a positive and a counter of
negative outcomes and then i just
calculate a ratio
now
so this is the
end of the game this is the algorithm
i'm using for the game master
should be part three order um so i have
an interaction i provide a mulligan
to the input because you would fail
immediately uh i i'm thinking of
mulligan i think i'm having this system
provide a mulligan of around five at
least for the initial interactions
because if you didn't then you just fail
the game immediately i don't want people
failing the game immediately that sort
of
is
wouldn't be a good idea so
but it can be any interactions
so
basically they just have to be within
these bounds
and then they have to initiate um
a stop to progress to a next state so
like
i'm thinking of
having like a neat state
where um you meet the individual or
having possibly a texting
state and then it goes from to other
places
there
then you can unlock new states but
they're only achievements i don't want i
mean
and
the achievements i want to
package
like
for like like going to a bar or like
going for coffee would be one bundle and
i have sets of bundles and i just
increase the achievements but it's still
open-ended like it's long
and
also with this game master you can
if you fail it immediately it just
restarts the game
for very obvious reasons
you still have to
i still have a lose condition well
on one side i could fail the game but on
the other side
i don't think that actually forgot that
what i really want to do is if you don't
fail the game you just get stuck in one
state with just like
friend zones so
that's another state so like as you can
see like all these states
i don't there's no end condition i mean
there are things you can do and you can
unlock but yes end conditions
and also if you
also maybe also if you you can also move
also you can move backwards from bundles
but a lot of these things are sort of in
flux and i'm
still designing it so that's why
it's like this
so
there's some prior work
and
these are the only two or three things i
was able to find so the ai dungeon is
is a text adventure using gpt3
which is uh
this is from a group called openai
although
gpt3 is owned by microsoft now
and in my opinion
although this is not
anything else i'm not seeing why
microsoft doesn't
just sell
buy out open ai because they have a lot
of their assets on replica ai had a
state machine that uses some text based
ai that is i don't think they're not
using deep learning they might be using
other systems or
or as smaller systems with a virtual
character
um basically we're different that we
model a conversation
um
specifically um dating um
and um we are using a model that is
generally used for carbon's conversation
called blenderbot
to indicate mood we use the pictures
manipulated to express this and we
figure out mood by using sentiment
analysis on the user input
so like that's a little about design but
you might wanna i might should have
actually done this further
so like a general visual novel is it's
many static branching paths and a visual
component in anime style with save
states so this gives you more into your
um context into what i was designing
before
and um why it's um
so
basically this is a text adventure like
done the
ai dungeon but it also has a visual
component but
instead of having a fixed set of
branches paths that you actually click
on it
will have a more higher set of branches
paths um we won't have even a set of
branching paths since you're interacting
with the conversational ai it doesn't
end um the visual component is gen will
eventually be either generated or
um
it will be us
it'll randomly select from already a set
of pictures that were already generated
beforehand
you'll still have save states
but
that's not
um
obviously
so this is a interesting data set
this is
um
um
by individual named gwern and of various
other people um that was crowdsourced so
they took a bunch of um
this is data set that i believe is
around four terabytes of um picture data
um and it's all tagged and it's an
illustration data set
of anime um anime pictures
this is what's used to power
a lot of
generative
picture systems
specifically of
people um
it is but it's also heavily biased into
females which is an issue with the data
set itself
um i think um
i don't i'm not sure
how to if they have a strategy to fix
that they also but i'm pretty sure it's
already tagged anyways
i'm not so
so here's like the road map that i have
in the current implementation like one
state is currently functional um
you can
show expressions of what agents
but i could but i was working on this to
fix and i'm working on using a visual
transformer maybe to also generate a
background instead of just using flickr
and then a style transfer
so style transfer is when um
you would um take
a set of
states like for instance this would be
like if you took a picture of yourself
and then use this data set
and then it would show you a picture of
yourself as like an anime character
so that might be a interesting thing to
add to the
system anyways but
so
plan on finishing this state machine and
also
um the controller um
unfortunately i also broke it so i don't
have a working
it's not uh
it's not really working a little bit
this um right now because i was trying
to implement some new features
um
like practice so
this is what it shows so far but
but
i don't really want
um unfortunately the background
obviously doesn't cover the foreground
so i need i'm probably going to have to
introduce some kind of alpha
transparency on the main image
to figure out probably using opencv or
something
to do that i mean
although
but um let's look at
here is a video
of how i how you can explore the light
and space
um and this is how i actually generate
like
the um characters
like you can see um
you can't see it very
let me do that again
so you can see that right now i have the
mouth open
um
and it just changed from
zero to negative thirty two three one
one five four five which is the
parameter
now i actually made this one i've had
i've actually seen um pictures where i
have like the open mouth and then it
goes closed but i really have to
reproduce this picture because it's
actually somewhat actually a picture of
one of them that's actually mad which i
don't have any
which i was never
able to reproduce and i think i can do
that by just taking a picture of this
and then putting it back in
i can possibly uh
maybe i'm just missing it there's
another thing you can do is
is that it'll probably pop up soon um
when you click batch and um
and then copy the torque it
yeah still playing
so when you click batch and combinatoric
um what it does is instead of instead of
having two images like zero and negative
33 it'll actually just just sample
across the plate and space
from this one to zero which means that
you have the
you have the expression that you want
so because it can sample because it
samples by just lowering this value to
zero
let me use
test
um i think i actually accidentally
generate a new
one
yeah so
basically you click on the
button you click on here to select the
mouth and then
it changes it by changing the value um
this tool is um called gan studio
it's
it's um
yeah i think i actually
and um
you can i also can see this um there's
another picture
i have this
but you can see like this you can uh do
a lot um this is how i actually generate
stuff
so like background is generated by anime
again too
version three is coming out soon the
text is generated by blender bar
the character the mood is generated by
um
is done by this
and um
and
and uh blender
is generated by gan studio
um
and uh blenderbot is from hugging face
they have a lot of transformer models
that are available
so
this is uh
this is a better image of the gameplay
that i made um
it's like you can see
the open face and the as the
it closes
um to a
smile so
then you can sort of see how it responds
so like let's go into the difficulties
in creating this
biggest problem i had like with
making this is um reproducing other
people's work i usually time box
reproducing others work um
i will only try to do it for an hour
if if if i can't reproduce your work in
an hour
i won't use it it's
then i'll try to use it another way
main issue is that the code
distributed doesn't work um either or
and not sure why
usually a lot of academic stuff is
um it's like post on the
use it once but
and it's very frustrating uh to even see
that and
i can it's also a red flag if it's i
can't reproduce your work um
but i don't know a lot about that even
the acm had that where they went i think
they sampled a bunch of uh work and then
they looked at how reproducible ones and
they were they got like around 50
percent that didn't work
i think like submitted conference papers
or something i don't know
it was like a while ago
um the second part um especially with
gpt3 is gpt3 is
um sort of like an app store like
concept
so you can use gpt3 they give you a
bunch of free
stuff um
queries but
eventually what happens is
you
you have to get approved by it
and they require the approval so i don't
really like
to be dependent on that
um
one
they could just choose to not up not to
approve it and then i can't really
you know the video game wouldn't work um
so i don't really like that i'd rather
replace it with something almost as good
the other problem is the
code and our data isn't available
i think this
i can understand the code on the data
not being available especially if it's
pretty large um but the code not being
available that's uh
even
bigger red flag
should be producing and i'm not sure why
people do that um they i mean they can a
lot of people cite that
it's um
at this point like when you get to
large generative ais that um language
models
there are obvious
i went i gave a talk
at
a hacking conference at dot com
um to on well i had some ideas on doing
large scales
um social
large scale social engineering using
language models
to
basically hijack twitter
i looked at that because first i was
trying to
looked at how easy it was to
manipulate people using um just
faking tweets and you could
and by scaling up by just buying
influencer
by just buying like um instagram
accounts or twitter accounts you could
it would cost you probably around twenty
thirty thousand dollars for the accounts
maybe
and then you could it would maybe cost
you six to twelve months
with it maybe two i could probably do it
myself or get two or three people
do it
i mean you could do it pretty large but
the problem is is that
it might be too expensive because you
could just also
do it the old-fashioned way but
the the this is it's gonna keep on
getting cheaper and cheaper
to do so it becomes a threat very fast
and i don't see a good mitigation
because even
facebook has their and facebook does
this
facebook does a pretty good job
to be honest about being
having
their models being open but
also
furthering the cause of
um being
responsible like fair seek
so they've defined basically
ways
of
um not just restricting
restricted models isn't really the
answer providing
a challenge or like a data set that
would
you know actually do the thing like
not to figure out if a model is could be
used hostilely like fair sequel and
others is a much better strategy because
you're not going to be able to control
us
these
published papers because it only
costs a few
it only costs a few like
nvidia cards
or
a bunch like a few hundred um a few ten
to twenty thousand dollars of cloud
credits to just reproduce your paper so
you just your own what you're only doing
is you're just
making it
just letting letting people reproduce it
they don't that have a
budget for like 10 to 20 thousand
dollars or more so right
i had some ethical considerations when
we designed this the game would be too
addicting to influence the people who
play the game in a larger negative way i
also thought of one where
if you play the game um you could also
use it hypothetically like just
to just play it against another um
person that doesn't know it's fake
although
not sure
that's a real big thing so
um
yeah so
um i did have a game demo but it wasn't
working as well um
so
i think that's uh it um so if anybody
has any questions
i
have some bibliography
now so yeah there's any um that's it for
the
presentation so
yeah thank you joshua um
wait a couple more seconds to see if
anyone puts any questions in the chat or
anyone is also free to unmute themselves
very interesting george
yeah oh thanks
well thank you for your talk josh um if
anyone has any questions that come up
later um feel free to reach out i think
he's on meetup and you can reach out to
us and we could
help you get in touch with him thanks
yeah thanks so much
okay thank you josh maybe i'll talk to
you more after this talk
okay sure
i'm curious about you
nice also
um i cannot play my slides
or i think they were a little bit typos
but i'll upload slides i had a um if
anybody wants them also so
yeah that would be great we can post
them on meetup as well
okay
bye everybody great have a good night
everyone
bye